i mean the question is i think we ask
you
all the time is how do you end up being
that person unless we see how these
people are human unless we see how
us and how they can end up there then
what's the point there's no such thing
as
villains and heroes we're not just born
that way
there's a twisty tiny you know confusing
path to where we end up
and i really wanted to show that it's
just got to be an environment where we
can all try stupid jokes we can try
different things and so i think our job
is to also be a part of that and
occasionally throw out a bad idea
we never really uh sought out funny
moments we let them happen
but like there was never any moment
where i was like i want a joke here i
want to laugh here it was just that like
if it was going to be funny let it be
funny
but never ever push and i remember
reading the book and laughing
and then at the same time going oh my
god we're all going to die
like you know it has this weird
combination which i think is kind of how
life
is
[Music]
[Applause]
i mean you know our idea was that we're
living in these times that are
so ridiculous and almost beyond
comedy but at the same time so tragic so
we tried to combine
both we tried to have a movie that was
tragic
heartbreaking but also absurd and
uh and and sort of falling over
itself kind of like the times that we
live in now
um we just felt like you know what is
the genre
of the time we live in right now yeah
what is it what is it
i mean if you could tell me i'd
appreciate it it's certainly not
straight comedy it's certainly not
straight drama it's kind of this
absurdist
cartoonish tragedy in a way i it's the
closest i can come slapstick tragedy
i like that i like that that's what we
have yeah you did something that i
didn't think possibly
a lot of bad stuff i knew all that bad
stuff and i it
but but you managed to locate a human
being or something
um i'm curious if you're getting that
response to it
well you know i had about five or six
years ago i was talking to a friend of
mine who was a screenwriter and i said
to him i said
you know and i really made this said it
was it was an aspiration at the time but
i was like
people are good people are like
scientifically
if you look at it when we're productive
when we're
loved and we love we do
physically better like that's an
empirical fact
and you know so i've done that show with
will ferrell
the one man show where he played bush
and by the end of it and i were like you
kind of feel a little bit
bad for bush and yet at the same time
[ __ ] him but you know what i mean like
it was this split
but i remember seeing this friend of
mine who's a screenwriter
uh in l.a that the one guy i can't
find that compassion for is dick cheney
and right away my friend said i have to
write that movie
so of course i said no and moved all of
my life and
have children did very well and then
eventually it came back around to this
and yeah yeah that's that's what
happened i mean the question is
i think we ask it all the time is how do
you end up
being that person and my editor said to
me
how does this guy sleep at night and i
said
hold on a second and i googled it and
sure enough there was an article in the
atlantic and he couldn't sleep at night
i mean that's a whole article about how
frank lutz is like what happened well i
i really feel like i think you maybe
agree with this
that like unless we see how these people
are human unless we see how they're
us and how they can end up there then
what's the point there's no such thing
as villains and heroes we're not just
born that way
there's a twisty tiny you know confusing
path to where we end
i was interested in this subject so i
got the book
and i knew it was michael lewis so
michael lewis is always very enjoyable
to read i'd read a couple of his things
before
and i picked it up one night i was in
bed it's like probably around 10 30 both
my daughters were in bed my wife was
next to me and i just started
i'll read 40 pages of it and i couldn't
put it down
and end up reading the whole book the
entire night
and i think i got done at like six in
the morning or something
and then the next i slept in till like
10 30 and my wife was like what is going
on what were you reading i was like i
just read the most amazing book
and i was telling her about it i was
telling you about the characters what
it's about how it kind of
threads all these different points of
view and lines and how it's like a get
rich story but then ultimately it's not
at all it's actually the story of like
you know
the fall of the banking system it's
about corruption it's about complacency
it's
funny it's heartbreaking and she's like
you should do it and i was like you know
i'm the guy who did step brothers like
i'm not i'm sure someone already has
this
so i didn't even look into it and then
it was like probably four years later my
agent
asked me uh at one point we'd come off a
pretty good
run of movies things were going well
he's doing rewrites and fixes on other
movies and he goes you know you're at a
place where
i can ask you this question you know if
you could do anything what would you do
so i started naming some other comedies
there was like you know i've done some
stuff that's sort of action oriented
even though it's comedy
so i started talking about some action
films and he goes no no anything
i go and right away i just before i even
knew i was saying i said well if i could
do anything i would do the big short
like why hasn't that been made into a
movie it's one of the
best books of this age that i've read
and he goes hold on one second
he hung up the phone and i went back to
whatever i was doing i kind of didn't
think anything was going to come of it
and he called me back and he goes all
right it's at plan b brad
pitt's company and the script they have
is kind of stalled
there's nothing going on with it and i
go would they
take a meeting with me he's like yeah
they were kind of excited about the idea
you know the characters are amazing but
part of the power of the book is that i
a guy who was an english major
who directed the movie step brothers
finished the book
and actually understood the shape of the
the fraud and the collapse
and that the information and the
characters almost went hand in hand
so we knew it was a really unusual
challenging movie in that sense
um that we had this like great cinematic
side to it which were the characters
but we also had this informational side
that was kind of crucial so
that was kind of when we talked about
the idea of breaking the fourth wall
and the idea of like giving information
in conjunction
i kept i i wanted to make sure if we're
going to do this movie that i
fully understood how the collapse
happens so i kept talking to economists
i kept reading books and then i would go
back to my wife
for starters who knows nothing about
finance and i would explain it to her
so then finally she said alright i get
it so then i went to my 10 year old
daughter pearl
and i would explain it to her and she
would go dad i'm so bored by this it's
all business
and then one day i explained it to her
and she's like that's kind of
interesting
so i knew i had it at that point you
know it was an interesting idea you know
we made a choice early on with the movie
that we weren't going to back
away from the actual information it's
been a lot of amazing wall street movies
made through the years like wolf of wall
street
margin call but none of them really ever
go into the actual
details of what happened so when i was
reading the book i thought wait a minute
you can do this
you just have to have a little bit of a
conversation with the audience
uh so our idea was we were going to use
pop culture we're going to use this sort
of pop culture that's around us all the
time and the question was what would
happen if that pop culture gave us
actual
information uh hence margot robbie in a
bathtub one of the things i think that's
genius about the movie is the way you're
able to balance these dramatic scenes
with the levity you injure you insert
this humor
with and i don't want to give away these
scenes but let's just say that you're
able to insert this humor
where did you realize or when did you
realize you wanted to do that and were
you nervous it wasn't going to work with
the tone or
you know we never really uh sought out
funny moments we let them happen
but like there was never any moment
where i was like i want to joke here i
want to laugh here it was just that like
if it was going to be funny let it be
funny but never
ever push but i think it was informed by
the book that i loved that the book had
all these different tones that there was
the
funny section about the president of aig
yelling at people because they left the
weights off the weight rack and like
and i remember reading the book and
laughing and then at the same time going
oh my god we're all gonna die like you
know it has this weird combination
which i think is kind of how life is uh
and especially if you're talking about a
bubble
an economic bubble there tends to be fun
times before it gets popped
you know you don't you would never want
to you're never the whole
key to the environment for improv is
you're never saying no you're never
saying that's wrong or not
good because the nature of improv is
you're just trying it and you know that
it's film so it's only going to be
one take that you're going to use so
what you're trying to do is kind of push
them in directions
and guide rather than saying no if it
became an environment where you're going
that wasn't good or
that didn't work you couldn't improvise
because everyone gets too tight at that
point so
it's just got to be an environment where
we can all try stupid jokes we can try
different things and
uh so i think our job is to also be a
part of that and occasionally throw out
a bad idea occasionally throw out a good
idea like you just kind of never know to
really jump in yes i sell a pitch but
they always know it's will ferrell so
it's
i i've rarely had to do the one where
you come in and pitch colds
so no i don't have great advice you know
i can oh well i can give advice from
this perspective we now have a
production company gary sanchez
and uh so we hear a lot of pitches so i
can give advice on from that side and
my big thing is i don't like it when
people walk you through the entire story
beat by beat like i feel like i don't
need to hear that yeah i feel like you
can give us the very broad strokes
and say you know it's the story of this
and the guy does this and you can kind
of hit your major scenes in like
five ten minutes and and then talk about
the style and talk about the actors you
envision and talk about some things you
think could be funny and
and that's like a pitch that i like is
like a nice little 10 15 minute pitch
they describe the movie the feel of it
what it could be
but as soon as i sit there and i hear
the person go into all right
we open on a street it's around 12 31
i'm just like oh god and then it all
becomes about making your face look
pleasant while you're hearing it
and i think the bottom line is pitching
sucks yeah
vice was nominated in the comedy
category of the golden globes
do you think the movie's a comedy and
like did you have any say
we had a big discussion about that with
the uh hollywood foreign press
i you know i honestly don't know i mean
we tried to make the movie to reflect
these insane times where
the example i keep using is when donald
trump was up in northern california
telling everyone we have to sweep the
woods
is that comedy or is that tragedy i
like if anyone could tell me the answer
to that i'll give the answer to what
vice is um because that's pretty
horrifying you have
thousands of people dying losing their
homes
and yet at the same time he's telling us
we have to sweep the forest
so we tried to have both of those
elements in this movie i also think that
w bush era was ridiculous
and at the same time murderous and
tragic
so they went comedy they ended up we all
ended up leaning comedy which i think is
fair
but uh i i i look at it more as a non i
i think we're in an age now where i'm
not sure genre plays anymore i mean look
at get out
i get out to me just transcended genre
i thought you know with our movie the
big short i thought we did a little bit
as well
so um i honestly don't know my hope
would be that people get really mad
and upset and they walk out and find out
who their congressman how he's been
voting he or she's been voting on
banking reform
that would be my dream my dream would be
that if everyone right wing and left
wing just said
if you're not for putting glass steagle
back if you're not for breaking up the
big banks i'm not going to vote for you
i don't care if you're right-wing or
left-wing you don't get my vote
and if we did that it would change like
that it would change in like two seconds
so that would be my hope is that people
you know pay attention
that would be great realistically one
movie's not going to do that
but if we could be part of an overall
movement an overall
dawning awareness i would be extremely
happy if
seven years from now people did wake up
to this and we were a little part of it
it would be great
you